bonsoir qui s'assoit même merci d'être
avec nous alors on l'a compris la
priorité affichée au vaccin mais surtout
accélération après la salve de critiques
comment vous accueillez vous voulez les
propos du premier ministre ce soir après
ce démarrage lent mais assumé par le
gouvernement
je suis tout à fait en faveur de cette
accélération de la campagne de
vaccination
on n'a pas attendu les déclarations
d'aujourd'hui puisque c'est en fait
depuis le début de la semaine qu'on
s'est attelé à mettre en place
rapidement des centres de vaccination au
sein des établissements pour les agents
hospitaliers et dans d'autres structures
comme la mienne pour les professionnels
de santé en dehors des pour les
prochaines de santé libéraux justement
là où vous êtes à strasbourg au chu
comment ça se passe concrètement est ce
que vous les avez ces doses de vaccins
déjà
oui nous avons ces vaccins depuis la
semaine du 27 décembre puisque la
campagne de vaccination devrait
commencer pour les seniors dans les
ehpad donc si l'accès à nous les avions
déjà et l'hôpital le chu et livrés
régulièrement au niveau des vaccins la
semaine dernière on donnera cette
semaine on aura normalement toutes les
semaines une livraison puisque chu va
délivrer du vaccin sur l'ensemble des
établissements de la de l'alsace en
tulle du bas rhin en tout cas au pardon
alors jean castex a annoncé des
objectifs clairs ce soir déjà il a dit
de 45000 personnes avaient été vaccinées
hier un million d'ici à la fin janvier
avec les plus de 75 ans à partir du 18
janvier cela vous semble crédible d
objectif tenable selon vont aujourd'hui
c'est bien d'avoir des objectifs on va
se donner tous les moyens pour y arriver
les choses pour aller plus ou moins a
progressivement mais on et off les
plages dans lesquels on propose la
vaccination des structures vont s'ouvrir
plus intensément et donc ça permettra
d'accueillir effectivement plus en plus
de monde
alors on l'espère en tout cas pour
vous-autres annonçe d'olivier
veron et pas des moindres la deuxième
dose de father ventech qui peut être
différée injuste qu'un je cite six
semaines au lieu de trois ans on sait
que d'autres pays ont fait ce choix le
royaume-uni le danemark mais à quels
impératifs répond qu il vraiment est-ce
que vous en tant que médecin vous fait
confiance en ce procédé qui on va pas se
mentir et peut-être une option choisie
pour aller beaucoup plus vite finalement
faute de doses disponibles
alors si on suit les les décisions
britannique le soient c'est pragmatique
et ils n'ont déjà montré par pour
d'autres vaccinations par ailleurs et
ils ont souvent les raisons je pense que
les données le suivi des données d'étude
sur les vaccins permettront de dire si
on peut effectivement espaces et c'est
le même principe que toute dose de notre
vaccin
on sait que si on fait une première dose
et qui a une deuxième dose même si celle
ci arrive un peu plus tard le système
immunitaire permet d'y répondre donc ça
je pense que les données scientifiques
permettront de de dire qu'effectivement
on pourra aller se passer mais ce qui
serait une bonne chose et une bonne
nouvelle puisque en ce cas là on
permettrait de vacciner bien plus de
monde
sachant qu'on pourrait étaler la
deuxième dose plus tardivement la
frontière allemande se plainent déjà des
troncs pénurie de vaccins est ce que
c'est quelque chose auquel on fera
forcément face en france
alors je dirais oui et non je comprends
je vois la situation en allemagne
puisque ils ont été près quelque peu
avant nous puisque fin novembre début
décembre était déjà dans les starting
blocks qu'ils attendaient plus que les
vaccins ils ont mis en place des grosses
structures de vaccination et qui fait
qu'ils ont peut-être pu vacciner plus
rapidement un grand nombre de personnes
mais la livraison des vaccins n'a pas
été plus importante pour autant est ce
qui fait qu ils peuvent se retrouver
aujourd'hui effectivement pour certains
centres fermés faute de vaccins mais je
crois qu'en israël ils ont vécu la même
chose
israël étant le pays le plus avancé sur
la couverture vaccinale est donc ils ont
tellement vite rapidement vacciner que
l'instant ils sont un peu bloquée faute
de vaccins disponibles
en tout cas l'europe pourra compter sur
un nouveau vaccin moderna qui a été
homologué un par l'autorité de santé
européennes
c'est une bonne chose cette
diversification de vaccin parce que
c'est vrai que quand on est français
qu'on n'y connais pas grand chose au
liban est ce qu'on va pouvoir choisir
entre tel ou tel vaccin oms dodik
certains sont plus efficaces que
d'autres que certains pourraient être
entre guillemets voilà plus pas plus
dangereux mais en tout cas partie des
français le penser puisque plus moderne
et moins connus alors juste pour revenir
peut-être sur votre question précédente
ça répondra aussi à celle là c'est que
en france est ce qu'on aura une pénurie
avec humour je dirais que non puisque si
50 ou plus 2% des les français ne
veulent pas se faire vacciner
il me restait que je pouvais dire qu'on
ne manquera pas de vaccin pour ceux qui
espèrent se faire vacciner mais ça c'est
un autre problème
l'arrivée du deuxième vaccin c'est une
excellente chose aussi c'est que ça
permet aussi d'augmenter
enfin la possibilité de vacciner plus de
monde alors les deux premiers par les
airs et moderna sont les vaccins de même
nature sont des vaccins arn messager
donc ça ne changera pas foncièrement les
choses après on attendra celui
d'astrazeneca
et puis effectivement lorsqu'on aura 4 5
vaccin à disposition en fait c'est
l'indication du vaccin que choisira le
médecin selon les personnes qui
pourraient être retenues vous fassiez
l'usure assez sceptique nombreux on a vu
encore voilà un représentant louis
foucher dans ce débat quel est notre
sentiment quand vous les entendez parce
que il faut voilà et vous le savez mieux
que personne il faut savoir que c'est
aujourd'hui près de la moitié de la
population française a tout de même
alors on peut comprendre mais le
questionnement et c'est tout à fait
normal de se questionner sur des
problématiques scientifiques sur des
médicaments dont on ne comprend pas le
fonctionnement ou comment ça a pu être
développé aussi rapidement et c'est bien
notre rôle nous médecins professionnels
répondre à ces questions puisque nous
lisons les données scientifiques les
publications et on se fait un avis tout
à fait clair sur la vaccination qui est
tout à fait utile qu'à montrer
son efficacité et son innocuité donc on
est là pour répondre donc le
questionnement des gens effectivement on
peut tout à fait le comprendre et on
doit répondre à ces questionnements
après il ya tout une affaire de
population qui est dans les thématiques
du complot et etc et qui sont un peu
victimes de toutes les informations qui
circulent sur l'acquis nation et il est
vrai aussi que les français sont un peu
champions malheureusement champion du
monde pour cette réticence à la
vaccination c'est une histoire très
ancienne dans le pays ce qui est un peu
paradoxal dans le pays de pasteur b
c'est un fait tout à fait établi
donc il faut peut-être un peu plus de
temps pour arriver à expliquer aux gens
et à les faire amener à prendre une
position pro maxime merci beaucoup
christophe hommel d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france ce soir